all right thank you very patient's been
a busy weekend you know adulting
doing adult things lifeing yeah i was
playing cyberpunk 2077.
but also doing other stuff is cyberpunk
2077
buggier than the program that built 2020
for us
almost also side note at the end the
very end of editing we're talking hours
of work i noticed this stain
right here on my shirt and i can't unsee
it
now you can't either hey gotta fill out
those tps reports
i cannot believe that reference is in
star wars i mean tps reports are a real
thing
might not be a reference but you know
they were all thinking it but anyhow
time to talk about mando last friday's
episode of mandel that is that would be
chapter 15 or season 2
episode seven second to the last and
let's face it it was what we thought it
was going to be which is the bill burr
show
just be real about it it was anyhow
mando cara dune
and fett as he's referred to which made
me feel good because my brother we all
call them fat right anyhow they go to
this prison planet pretty much like
rura pente but no snow he's just working
on machines
doing whatever you know like we need to
fill the time i don't know work on that
piece of junk and they're like we need
your help so he's like okay cool so
now they have a crew also boba fett has
his newly painted armor
looks all sleek not gonna lie it looks a
little too clean for me i guess it's
just weird i've never seen boba fett's
armor without scuffs and
bruises and scratched up paint and
granted
in mandalorian it was scratches and
scuffs to the 10th degree but now he's
like look at that
new paint job but the paint's too clean
anyhow it's pretty miniscule but
i'm saying it's weird but anyhow they
have to drive this transport
that's pretty much carrying galactic
nitroglycerin they have to take it into
this base and then go to this little
computer and
all right get the information now they
know where to find them off gideon in
which there's a scuffle to throw down a
fight
which i do like the fact that mando
started getting
rocked like his armor started getting
beaten up and chipped it
it kind of shows that he got lazy with
his impervious mandalorian armor and he
made jokes about the fact that this guy
can just take all the hits but
when you're able to take all those hits
you start getting lazy it's like a
mortal kombat 11 you do the towers of
time and you have all your augments so
you have
shields for four hits you know your hits
hit harder your special moves hit harder
you're just farming augments consumables
gear i move rambo i can kill a dude in
one hit
it's no problem then you fight online in
the combat league and you're like oh i
got lazy off those augments i shouldn't
do that so much if i'm gonna go
here every once in a while it's the same
thing you know you get lazy
i do like the fact that this show showed
that with mando dude took some hits some
hits that he probably thought hey my
armor's oh yeah this isn't that armor so
anyhow they have to go in there and bill
burr was gonna do it you know
the thing has the computer has to see
your face and he's like i served under
that guy i can't do it you have to do it
and mando actually does it he takes off
the helmet
which it shows how close he is with the
kid i also feel like that's just
it's kind of a tradition at this point i
suppose one episode
every season is gonna have him take off
his helmet but it does show the process
of someone questioning his religion you
know he's now met mandalorians who were
like you don't take off your helmet oh
you're one of those mandalorians you're
one of the craziest
he's like shut up we're the true
mandalorian so he's been shown by other
mandalorians that you don't have to
actually be that stringent on the rules
and the first season
was a robot so there was a loophole
there in this season he's doing it
because he genuinely cares
about grogu which is something that
that's what this episode did for me see
before i always saw
mando as grogu's babysitter you know
he's tasked with carrying this kid yes
they have a connection
groger really loves it wow i've called
him grogu not baby yoda
the point is grogu always liked mando
and he has that connection with mando as
ahsoka said but in this episode grogu is
referred to as oh they took his kid
this was the episode that i really felt
like mando
was grogu's father which is a great
thing because the whole theme of this
show
with mando's character is the fact that
family and bloodline are different
things but this was the episode i really
felt like
mando accepted the fact that he is a
father to grosgu that's how grogu sees
it
and that's how he sees it so yeah not
surprising he takes off the helmet he's
like i'll do it for my son
it's fine then they have a sit down with
the biggest [ __ ] looking son of a
[ __ ] ever
it was bothering me for a while i was
like where have i seen this dude a slew
of rob zombie movies
absolutely but he either killed the
waynes or he was grand moff tarkin's lap
dog point is the guy just looks like
trouble also yeah to kill the wayne's
reference
he was joe chill and batman begins
anyhow they sit down they're all talking
about yeah the empire this the empire
that and bill burr just starts
monologuing we're like yeah you remember
the battle of serenity valley
we lost a lot of good men out there
mando's like don't do it dude don't do
it you're like
this guy's gonna eat [ __ ] this officer
is just gonna get shot i thought he was
gonna shoot him under the table you know
like han solo did with greedo
no he just bam in the chest and then
enter the fire fight the fire fight
begins they get out of there
slave one picks him up and he drops that
charge and when he dropped that seismic
charge
you recognize it because in attack of
the clones
it's what top three member it might be
two
it's a very memorable thing from episode
two so when that charge dropped i
i audibly out loud in my living room
went bam
sure enough bam
then they get away again another piece
of the member berries but
i dug it i did like i mean this episode
has a few of the member berry soup
but i enjoyed it i enjoyed the fact that
boba fett's like they might recognize my
face if i go in i was like
logistically that's true some of the
older commanders might be like wait a
minute
didn't you serve under me you know when
you were a clone trooper i recognized
that mug
and in the end mando sends a message to
moff gideon which
thank you internet for all the taken
memes because it's essentially that
he's just like i will find you and i
will kill you
that's right papa bear is coming and he
is pissed and i am left with that
feeling of uncertainty
for the next episode the season finale
of season two because logistically you
look at it i mean mando's coming for
grogu he's coming for
him i don't think moff gideon should die
because boca tan is looking for moff
gideon
and if moff gideon just dies well there
goes that unless boko tan comes into the
next episode but still
i'd like to see more of a search with
her looking for him and now you find the
irony or at least the humor and the fact
that if bo catan had just stuck around
mando and was like hey i'll join you for
this series for this season anyway
she'd have found moff gideon a lot
faster i mean the empire's looking for
grogu
she's looking for moff gideon logic
would say
she'd be like well i'll stick around you
and
the bait but i hope she's having fun on
her quest but in the episode before this
mando's ship was blown up that thing was
just destroyed
we're not just like oh it might be
pieced back together it was
humpty dumpty got a big laser blast from
an imperial
cruiser yes comment section anyhow there
was a smoking crater
and that was that so mando has no ship
and him traveling around in the slave
one
it doesn't work the dude needs another
ship which maybe that'll happen maybe
he'll just go to moff gideon's
wallet after he beats his ass he's like
hey i'm taking this i'm buying a new
ship with your credits but logistically
mando's ship was blown up but
the show doesn't really work it won't
work long term for mando to be a
passenger in the slave one and now
boba fett it's been retconned it was
like bubba fett and jango fett
were mandalorians and then they weren't
mandalorians then jango fett was a
foundling
which i guess means boba fett is now a
mandalorian because i guess
mandalorian status is passed down like
usaa insurance i didn't know that
i just didn't i'm not even making jokes
i didn't know that if someone's a
mandalorian if they have a kid
regardless
that kid's now a mandalorian i don't
know in which now that grogu
is essentially like mando's son and
mando was a foundling does that mean
grogu is
a jedi mandalorian
[ __ ] i mean that's probably the coolest
star wars title you can
ever have ever anyhow i'm a little
concerned because the possibility does
exist that
mando gets killed and boba fett takes
over the show
and it being called the mandalorian
makes sense that might be the reason for
the retcon of the retcon
also the reason that mendo's ship got
blown up i don't want that to happen i
don't i think that would be lazy
cheap and i think his character deserves
more than that and essentially his show
has deserved more than it's gotten
because right now his show feels like
like i've said before it feels like a
springboard to springboard other
shows and that's kind of the point of
the mandalorian i would like them to
focus it up and make the show more about
him
for the sake of him and grogu they're
the heart of the show they're the soul
of the show so i'd like season three to
really concentrate on them
not so much hey we need to do what we
need to do to springboard other shows
off of this show that said i do like the
fact that i have that uneasy feeling
because that gives me the feeling of i
don't know what's going to happen in the
finale mando could die
gideon could die i don't want either to
die or mandel could get grogu back
mando and gideon they both live but now
we start seeing what moff gideon's plan
is and mando's like we got to stop him
so we'll see but for the next episode
the finale of season two
i am nervous it's kind of a cool feeling
i just don't want anyone to die alright
so last friday's episode of the
mandalorian season 2
episode 15 chapter 17. no
chap no season 2 episode
7 or chapter 15 of the show
as a whole what did you think whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you